you've uh briefly pondered running for
governor I don't know if that's in your
future I hope it is uh you had a few
good lines about it
do you think about that kind of stuff
about what the future holds in terms of
uh political office I don't think about
it in terms of political office I've
I've graduated to a broader larger
thought of what's my future hold and and
where
and
would I be most useful as a
leader I think that's a fair word
whether that's
thought whether that's
leader of my family right now so it's a
parent father
um
the leader of
people that work with me
um
politics is it's it's
I'm not going to say it's it's because
it's not it's not small and I'm not I
don't I don't that's that's why I say
that out loud it's not small I do think
it needs to re-engineer and re-define
what its purpose is before because it's
just chasing its own tail right now with
the with the with the with the two
parties uh that are seem to me to be
completely about just invalidation of
the opposition instead of vision of
themselves
um
so I think it needs redefinition of what
it is because it is important that's
what I mean that's why I said I don't
mean small it's it's it needs to think
bigger about what it is and how it's
useful when it seeks to invalidate it's
small when it seeks vision
it can be big yes well one's affirmative
one's going into that cynicism we were
talking about yeah you know and
validation of any opposing thought or
maybe that were even opposing opposition
is a is a is a is an is an arrogant term
that's too strong it's a lot of times
not even opposition alternative other
than another way of thinking about it oh
could both be true oh how can we parlay
those two ideas
um you know this the the the one of the
challenges with
these ideas of a third party or Mitch in
the middle
it's kind of got this historic notion of
being oh well
it's sort of Mr in between kind of go
which way the wind blows
I think done in the right way it's the
and it doesn't have to be under a third
party's name necessarily but it's
actually an incredibly rebellious
position right now and it's actually
and I love sports
it's tactically
the place with which
to move most advantageously I think of
their free safety in the game of
football
they're in the middle of the field and
they're deep they choose to defend left
or right according to the play that's
been called by the offense
similar to the offense the running back
you read the deepest and then you're
going to run right to run left to go
away from that opposition it's it's a
tactical spot to be truly independent
and respond
so do you think you have a role in that
in political officers I don't know I it
don't it's on mine it's not out of my
mental mental box
um and I gave it real sincere thought
and discernment for over a year
and it's a wonderful whether whether I
end up whether I end up in politics or
not it was a wonderful exercise one that
if anyone else got time to do it do it
to ask yourself what you would do if you
were CEO yeah of a state CEO of a Nation
CEO oh the world that's a great thing to
go you want to get your values line you
want to admit where you lie and throw
yourself some pop quizzes and what if
this phone call comes at 4am
what you gotta you know who you want to
surround yourself with it's really great
questions to ask and I think has helped
me
on a more micro level be a better father
a better man taking considerations that
I did not maybe take in as seriously
before considering it
um I don't know if that's in my future I
got you know useful is a big word it's
got to be I would have to be useful
I have to be useful in the right way and
is that my Lane to be most useful
it's a good question for leader to ask
how can I be useful